a lagoon of poverty we are passing by
people who live in inhumane surroundings
meet a Torsen whom family they were
evicted from their heart just like tens
of thousands of others in recent years
in Lagos Pascal a father of five was
already poor before the eviction but he
says at least he had a livelihood no
real house no boat no business during
the day we can stay here to prepare one
meal at night we have to sleep outside
in the rain this is something no human
being should experience I'm in Wado
today's meal tomato soup and this pot of
cassava must feed several families in
the neighborhood this is just one family
an estimated 87 million people that's
roughly half of Nigeria's population are
thought to be living on less than one
dollar ninety cents per day nigeria has
overtaken india as the country with the
largest number of people living in
extreme poverty these young men and
women are newly minted volunteers in
their slums they are being trained how
to let others know what kinds of rice
they have before they are evicted the
ultimate goal is to stop extreme poverty
from spreading I want to change the
poverty level in my community and
provides 11 other communities that means
knowing how to mobilize other people so
that lawmakers do their job and solve
the deteriorating situation in slums
Magan Chapman found that the justice and
empowerment initiative five years ago
she says eviction creates more extreme
poverty unfortunately the government is
not working with those people hand in
hand to eradicate poverty and help them
to find a solution to their situation
instead the government is putting in
place policies that actually criminalize
the the livelihoods of the urban poor
and demolish and destroy their homes the
government wants to turn waterfront
slums into attractive property it says
they must be shut down because they are
a breeding ground
for crime and harmful to the environment
but for half of llegas residents on the
brink of extreme poverty the slums are
for better or for worse their home